è la tutti ragazzi e benvenuti a questo
video sono parigi oggi siamo su un gioco
nuovissimo tra l'altro della epic games
che tra lo ringrazio per aver
sponsorizzato questo video o uno dei
nomi più belli del pianeta si chiama
perché ciò l'effetto speciali vorrei
dice il robot è un gioco dai colori
sfavillanti sfavillanti perché spari
cominciamo è anche ditte tra i ragazzi
prima di cominciare volevo dirvi che
trovate in descrizione link del gioco
che lo trovate sia su playstation 4 che
su pc a 16 euro 15 99 cacciamoli precisi
se lo prendete utilizzate il mio codice
creatore valigie tv che giampiero sta
facendo a comparire alla mia sinistra
des sinistra di rai ragazzi che possiamo
immergerci nel mondo di san siro ma ora
cosa devo fare
ok non picchiare scritte erano solo la
prima partita spiegatemi va bene allora
picchiate anna io sono contro di lui ed
evo devo bild armi fortissimo per poi
andare contro di lui alla fine sarà uno
scontro mortale tra me luglio devo
capire bene le tattiche e robe del
genere per adesso sto dando non c'è
niente di troppo strano forse è meglio
se io sposti la webcam cosa che ho
trovato una chitarra un liuto va bene
prendo il liuto e anzi prendo i comuni
pugnali che mi sembrano un po più potere
le profondità del sotterraneo senti
della squadra blu scattate anzi voli
ogni aiuto allora cola e lascia che la
bellezza vedo che è già avanti invece di
recuperare un pochettino ma ce la farò
tranquilli alla porta ma feroce via un
altro po io ci schiatto qua
smettila niente a me lasciamo perdere ok
a c'è una specie di di ordine da seguire
che hai uno no allora uno è questo uno
due o 50 per cento ragazzi secondo voi
non ci posso credere non mi ha mai
successo nella vita
caccia al tesoro e dov'è e dietro avanti
dietro anti anti anti anti veloce veloce
veloce che l'altro ancora non ha trovato
veloce
certamente bisogna superare delle stanze
armatura verde con la verde ha dato il
suo armatore in cui io direi che ancora
secondo me bisogna superare delle stanze
arrivare per primi al finale in modo
tale da surclassare il nostro avversario
teoricamente dovrebbe essere questa cosa
serve il potere speciale del di voto
dove ancora non ho capito ma sei freddie
mercury milan o no l'hack è male troppo
schietto io ragazzi ecco non so bene
cosa succede se schiatti questo era cosa
un po strano
l'hacker muoio sono morto sono un pirla
quindi a mi fa risuonare al post di kami
cosa ci trovi dentro una comune e spada
secondo me è molto più potente quella e
l'incantesimo fuoco di muro o cadamuro
fuoco muro non ha letto bene va bene
proviamo un attimo porca vacca ciò il
mana quindi teoricamente usiamo le
circostanze intelligenti non qua perché
teoricamente quasi tutte devono solo un
mese fa tanto da una grande campagna
signore tartaruga ya quando vai a fuoco
il tuo personaggio
occorre completamente a causa concesso
un motivo corre il ritorno va bene ok
questo
fuori avevi che ce lo scudo e consolare
non avevo capito bene ma io posso andare
a cos'è sta roba qua che non corro hanno
capito si sblocca al muro ok però un
savani alzare per prendere i punti vabbè
dai mancano tre minuti ragazzi in tutto
questo e non so se lo scadere di tre
minuti alla fine serve semplicemente per
vedere chi è arrivato più avanti e e
niente poi la fine allo scadere ci mette
tutti contro tutti quindi è una gara a
chi arriva più avanti degli altri giusto
teoricamente voi non lo so cos'è sta
roba armature in cui in metallo vai con
l'armatore in metallo teoricamente ci
siamo che io le sto mettendo secondo le
mie idee perché non so sempre
statistiche sono giuste prove allora ok
agli animali nulli poco bellissimo
vedete quello spiazzo davanti e tutti
quelli davanti a te non riescono a
beccarti teoricamente ci passano in
mezzo e quindi schioppa no o non ci
passano proprio perché non ci hanno
voglia sono pigri sono morte non ho
schivato la fine dai non sono riuscito
ad accendere nuda veda in rissa abbiamo
fatto cinque livelli a testa li ho fatti
di una lentezza spropositata però va
bene teoricamente qua ci dovremmo essere
ragazzi dovremmo essere contro il nostro
avversario al nostro stesso livello vi
teoricamente e combattuta gara delle
lumache pronti fai correre più lontane
una lumaca va bene ma basta sua squadra
blu
ieri ci sono solo io e la squadra verde
morta c'è proprio defunta anche in parte
anche alla squadra gialla o no lo sapevo
quindi ragazzuoli la mia l'ho macchia
più bella è capito come faceva
assemblata aveva fatto niente ma se non
ho fatto niente
però c'è corri puledra e come faccio a
un pezzo del culo è un pezzo di schifoso
l'aido togliti ma come ozzy ha chiuso il
muro di fuoco rete grady aspetta che non
ho capito che devo fare qua bagnate sta
cosa come hai fatto come ha fatto come
ha fatto spiega meno
e come fai come ha fatto a dove lancia
capirla dove lanciarli su sti cosi ok ok
ok ok
perché non lo sapevo che lo aspetta
aspetta aspetta ma anche in passato e
sono passati vantaggio perché il mio
adorato e tanto lo picchio schiatta e
mori che devo vincere io schiatta
smettila hai rotto dei morire o ci sono
gli avversari e va bene adesso posso
concentrarmi sul vincere il mio adorato
vale un sacco di più del suo quindi il
mio dorato
all'inizio ha fatto fare più punti di
quanto non ne faccio al suo che normale
quindi ragazzi quelli dorati per passare
in vantaggio ricordatevelo molto bene mi
dispiace aver picchiato il mio
avversario ma solo non vincevo perfetto
perfetto ormai raga un mega vantaggio
guardali guarda che mira che ciò
incredibile
teoricamente ragazze il tipo non mi
colpisce ho vinto io perché c'è
come fa a essere più veloce di me io
colpisco le mie rom è praticamente vinco
io no no no non l'ha preso quello dorato
dove fa niente porca vacca provato a
deviarlo non son riuscito dai veloce lo
marca stupida quanto tempo ok 10 9 ho
vinto io
non è detto è però ragazzi attenzione
proprio lui o ragazzi sono stati bravi
ne dovrei farlo con noi iscritti ragazzi
sto video cioè un video con voi perché
sarebbe molto figo sia ora che è un
attimo è partita subito ci siamo e prova
a giocarmi l'ultima prevedere se riesco
a farla decentemente siamo non serve in
46 in 2 stavolta di nuovo dai caccia al
tesoro
la spada normale attrezzatura pala o
attrezzatura boomerang è questo qua
scusa attrezzatura boomerang
innanzitutto comune spada oraro pugnali
nobile e raro pugnali mi piace di più
perché i pugnali sono più veloci stata
attaccata da smanettoni di brutto e il
boomerang tornerà indietro
che schifo però che fa di danno
teletrasporto bellissimo che epico tra
la ecco la stanza del boss sopra l'unico
del muco kings line board va bene cioè
trasporto raga incredibile dovrebbe
funzionare abbastanza bene teoricamente
cioè vedo che era
tra l'altro dei pico miticamente dove
funzionare da paura con il man city
teletrasporta da una parte all'altra
teoricamente se vi teletrasporto e uso i
pugnali il tipo non mi becca pv alla
fine sembra che non facciamo la corsa
delle lumache di potrebbe essere un
problema tech tech 123 daytona più bravo
secondo me i ragazzi ha dato più avanti
l'altro perché io lo posso non riesco a
farlo fuori
scade il tempo prima ok una andato
veloce e lo so
sta per iniziare la rissa veloce dai dai
daniele che o il bonus
l'ho fatto fuori caccia al tesoro raro
bastone ok 5 armatura d'oro perfetto va
bene dovrei solo preso l'ho preso preso
ce l'ho fatta ho preso il bonus in
tempismo per la rissa finale
praticamente non ci dovrebbe essere
forse roero più avvantaggiato con i
pugnali di prima zaino aspetta che ti
trovo poi vediamo che passa in vantaggio
ecco qui
4 da non lo fa o non riesco a fare
niente
ma cosa fai pa pa pa non sei sparando
nulla e scarso ide se io no vabbè c'è
una differenza di danno imbarazzante
cioè lui mi attacca io muoio lui forse
mi ammazza tre volte io abbiamo fatto
fuori una volta sola c'è poi sbarazzate
va bene ma non devo niente ma fa
veramente pena io ho cambiato nel
bastone perché credevo nel bastone fa
veramente schifo ma dai
vabbè ho perso cosa avevo detto prima
non sembra qui pato bene questo era
ready set kraus che trovate in
descrizione perché ho detto col codice
che network abc tv assolutamente perché
ha un prossimo video iscrivetevi canale
lasciate un mi piace è un commento su
questo gioco come vi sembra e vi voglio
vedere tutti online così facciamo le
sfide insieme tanto avete vittoria
facile e io mi sono veramente impegnato
per ragazzi
[Musica]